[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
March 17th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
there are some unexpected ways you can
reduce your tax bill a few have to do
with medical expenses wsj tax reporter
Laura Saunders went through the list of
expenses that qualify and she joins me
now hey Laura thanks a lot for being
here well thanks for having me so Laura
you know for a lot of people medical
expenses are covered by insurance so how
can these expenses make their way onto
someone's tax return I would say that
not all medical expenses are covered by
insurance and if they're not covered by
insurance if they're unreimbursed they
might be able to be deductible as
medical expenses on your tax return on
schedule a as an itemized deduction I
guess we're talking about more than just
the cost of a doctor's visit yes we are
it could be all kinds of things that
relate to health and expenses for health
or for illness and for instance we point
out that the cost of a home elevator if
someone is disabled could be deductible
now that's not a small cost also tuition
maybe fifty thousand dollars of tuition
a year to a special needs School fees
for assisted living and nursing homes
and things like that and also even a
swimming pool well hold on a swimming
pool you put a pool in the backyard and
it's deductible I've heard of more than
one that was deductible it may not be
fully deductible but in the case that
I'm thinking of the CPA had a client who
was building a house and putting in a
pool recommended by a doctor for a
family member's chronic illness now
that's not great to have a chronic
illness but it is nice to have a
swimming pool and so the cost of that
was deductible okay so these are things
that are serving a medical needs so you
can't just put a pool in you have to
have some sort of a doctor's note yes
you
also have to have an appraisal of the
home's value be before
and after you make the Improvement like
the elevator or the swimming pool and if
it increases the value of your home you
have to subtract that from the deduction
all right so what else qualifies for the
deduction oh just so many things large
and small including for instance
bandages breast pumps guide dogs contact
lenses and contact lens solution
Dentures stop smoking programs obesity
treatment all kinds of things like that
bandages so if I buy bandages can I just
turn around and deduct those well I
don't think you can deduct Band-Aids but
let's say you had surgery and you needed
special bandages and maybe even you
needed a lot of them that could be part
of your medical expenses that are
deductible all right so I would imagine
a lot of people aren't familiar with
this legal deduction to put on their tax
return yes that's right they aren't only
about 4 million tax filers out of maybe
160 million took it in 2020 money that's
the most recent data we have but it's
interesting that the average deduction
was twenty two thousand dollars wow yeah
so when it rains maybe it pours I mean
nobody's happy about having medical
expenses but it can be pretty good to
get a deduction when you have them so
what's the math here can you deduct the
entire cost of say a guide dog or a pool
well how it works is that there are two
limits that trip up a lot of people one
is that you must itemize your deductions
on schedule a you can't just take the
standard deduction of course ninety
percent of Americans now take the
standard deduction but the other thing
is that you can only deduct expenses
that are greater than seven and a half
percent of your adjusted gross income
now just as gross income includes your
wages and investment income and things
like that it does not include your
deductions and your standard deduction
so if a couple had two hundred thousand
dollars of income then they couldn't
deduct the first fifteen thousand
dollars of eligible expenses so this has
to be a robust number to really be able
to show up as a deduction in many cases
it
Dove for the year you see all right but
what if someone's medical expenses
aren't high enough to qualify for this
particular deduction what else should
they be aware of well I think it's
important to be aware of the breadth of
this deduction because the same list
that applies for medical deductions also
applies for fsas that's flexible
spending accounts and hsas and so it's
kind of one list and so there's a lot to
know here maybe you have extra FSA money
go read the list and see if there's
anything on that that applies to you the
other thing is that if someone does get
over that hurdle the seven and a half
percent hurdle then all kinds of things
that wouldn't be deductible all of a
sudden are deductible so maybe you're
putting in the elevator but you have a
lot of contact lens solution so so
that's why I think it's good for people
to know about this because I don't think
they generally do so what sorts of
medical expenses aren't allowed to be
deducted well there's a list of those
too and in both cases this is just an
idea the IRS might attack something we
can talk about that in a minute but you
can't deduct cosmetic surgery to improve
your appearance although I think you
could deduct plastic surgery say after
an accident or something so it's just
some sort of elective surgery for tummy
Tucker or something like that yeah and
you can deduct hair transplants
Health Club dues or weight loss programs
that are to improve your General Health
and you can't deduct funeral expenses I
guess well once you're gone you're gone
yeah you can't take the money with you
yeah how do dependents fit into this
equation well you can deduct your
dependence expenses too particularly if
you have a sick child but there's
something quite interesting if you
support someone and you meet all the
tests of a dependent it would typically
be a relative or a friend who lives in
your house an elder person and they meet
all the qualifications of being a
dependent except they may have more than
four thousand dollars of income a year
in this case if you pay their medical
expenses you can deduct them on your own
tax return oh so that gets swept up into
this eligibility yes and people don't
know that it's called a medical
dependent and it's a very good thing to
know about so let's go back to the list
of things that are deductible for a
moment is it a finite list or is it the
sort of thing where sort of see what
looks like a qualifies and what doesn't
could make the list might not well I
think that's a really important question
to ask because the irs's list even
though it's 10 pages long is only just a
sample you know they're examples the law
is very clear and there may be things
that are not on the list that are
allowed and we came across a tax court
case where a woman took thirty thousand
dollar deduction for so-called energy
healing for severe spinal problems and
she's been told that surgery could hurt
her and the IRS rejected it and she went
to Tax Court and she won her thirty
thousand dollar deduction so there's
leeway here in the law and the judges
can apply it so that was something not
on the list that was determined could or
should be on the list yes all right
that's Wall Street Journal tax reporter
Laura Saunders Laura thanks again for
being with us thank you for having me
and that's it for your money briefing
this week your money briefings producer
is mohsin Ali our supervising producer
is Melanie Roy and our executive
producer is Chris zinsley I'm your host
J.R Whalen thanks for listening and have
a great weekend
[Music]